lo que tenemos aquí son curvas de oferta
y demanda que representan un modelo para
el mercado de alquiler de vivienda en
una ciudad determinada estadounidense
este eje vertical derecho aquí es el
precio de renta en términos de dólares
por pie cuadrado por mes así que si
tienes un departamento de mil pies
cuadrados con el precio rondando por
aquí entonces la renta es de mil dólares
por mes este eje de acá el horizontal
está en una escala de millones de pies
cuadrados por mes un millón de pies
cuadrados dos millones de pies cuadrados
etcétera
como lo hemos hecho en los últimos
vídeos donde hemos estado hablando del
superávit del consumidor y desde el
productor consideraremos la curva de
demanda por acá en azul como una curva
de beneficio marginal para los primeros
pies cuadrados de por aquí la cantidad
de beneficio que les corresponde a los
inquilinos es decir a los consumidores
es enorme para ellos tiene un valor de
más de 4 dólares por pie cuadrado quizás
nos lo que van a pagar por el
departamento pero eso es lo que vale
para ellos
también voy a considerar esta curva de
oferta como una curva de costo marginal
o del costo de oportunidad de producir
esas unidades adicionales por acá a la
derecha cuando tenemos muy pocos pies
cuadrados tal vez la tierra más barata
está disponible o quizás es la que es
más adecuada para la construcción así
que el costo de oportunidad para los
proveedores de los pocos primeros pies
cuadrados es muy bajo por eso tiene
sentido que se oferte el producto en
este caso vivienda puesto que el costo
de producción es muy bajo y el beneficio
para los consumidores que es muy alto si
el precio está en cualquier lugar entre
estas dos curvas el consumidor tendrá
algún beneficio y los productores
también no obtendrán una ganancia así
que el mercado como un todo va a estar
obteniendo un montón de superávit
repartido entre consumidores y
productores de acuerdo con el precio
brevemente recordemos que las unidades
que estamos usando son pies y dólares
puesto que estamos considerando un
mercado estadounidense
bien retomando el asunto del precio los
productores van a seguir produciendo más
y más pies cuadrados de vivienda
mientras que el beneficio marginal sea
mayor que el costo marginal mientras
esto pase existe un superávit que puede
ser repartido entre consumidores y
proveedores en función del precio el
beneficio marginal excede al costo
marginal hasta que llegamos a este punto
azul de aquí este punto corresponde a 3
millones de pies cuadrados por mes
después de ahí ya no tiene sentido
seguir agregando pies cuadrados al
mercado supongamos que hay constructores
que dicen hay que añadir algunos pies
cuadrados más al mercado pues les va a
costar más de 3 dólares y quienes renten
ni siquiera van a obtener estos dólares
de beneficio así que no hay razón para
que alguien quiera construir más allá de
este punto de intersección así que 3
millones es la cantidad de equilibrio y
el precio que le corresponde la gente
dibuje todo para que salieran números
bonitos es de 3 dólares por pie cuadrado
al mes 3 dólares por pie cuadrado al mes
es un alquiler muy caro si tienes un
departamento de mil pies cuadrados que
es como un antiguo departamento de dos
recamaras y dos baños
que le corresponde es de tres mil
dólares al mes eso es lo que uno
esperaría pagar en una ciudad como san
francisco
bien pues pongamos ahora que al alcalde
no le gusta esta situación y dice esto
es impagable a la gente no le alcanza
para vivir en nuestra ciudad así que
instituye un control de alquileres un
control de los alquileres es
esencialmente un precio máximo para la
renta es decir la renta por pie cuadrado
no puede estar por encima de una cierta
cantidad mensual así no es normalmente
como se aplica el control de los
alquileres pero supongamos que si para
ahorrarnos bastantes problemas con el
modelo lo que normalmente se hace es que
no se puede aumentar la renta más allá
de una cierta cantidad en nuestro caso
entonces fijan un precio máximo para las
rentas le ponen un tope a la renta con
un precio máximo de dos dólares por pie
cuadrado dos dólares por pie cuadrado
analicemos lo que va a suceder nos vamos
a fijar en lo que va a suceder con el
superávit del productor y al superávit
del consumidor antes de hablar del
control de renta hablemos un poco acerca
de la ganancia en el mercado primero
veamos el superávit del consumidor con
el precio justo por aquí en azul el
consumidor tenía un superávit igual a
esta área de por acá vamos a calcularlo
digamos que este extremo en la curva
está en 4.5 entonces este lado vertical
del triángulo va a medir 1.5 la base del
triángulo por aquí es de 3 millones así
que el área es de 3 x 1.5 / 2 que es 4.5
entre 2 4.5 millones es el área del
rectángulo entero se divide entre 2 para
obtener el área del triángulo así que el
resultado nos da dos puntos 25 millones
recordemos que el eje horizontal está en
millones de pies cuadrados por mes muy
bien entonces antes del control de
alquileres con la cantidad de equilibrio
y el precio equilibrio de un mercado
libre el superávit del consumidor es de
2.25 millones de dólares que es el
beneficio colectivo de los consumidores
sobre lo que tienen que pagar por vivir
en esas casas vale en el caso del
superávit del productor que es toda esta
área sombreada de aquí nos fijamos en el
extremo inicial de la curva de oferta
para bajarnos cuentas horrendas digamos
que está en 50 centavos así que todo
este lado vertical del triángulo va a
medir 2 dólares con 50 centavos y este
lado horizontal igual que en el caso
anterior tiene longitud de 3 así que el
área vale 2.5 por 3 por un medio 2.5 por
3 nos da el área de todo el rectángulo
así que hay que dividir entre 2 para
obtener el área de este triángulo
déjenme escribir esta multiplicación acá
abajo
entonces 2.5 por 3 nos da 7.5 y nos
falta que llega entre 27.5 dividiendo
entre 2 más da
75 entre 23 30 y 7.5 por lo que esto va
a ser 3.75 así que el superávit del
productor viene a ser de 3.75 millones
de dólares
y de nuevo el superávit es la ganancia
que los productores reciban más allá de
esos costos de producción
entonces el superávit total el beneficio
total que tiene el mercado en conjunto
es decir sumando el superávit de los
consumidores y el de los productores es
de 2.25 más 3.75 por lo que alcanzamos
un total de 6 millones de dólares de
superávit vamos a notar los 6 millones
de dólares de superávit total qué bien
esto ocurre porque estamos en un punto
de equilibrio eficiente con un buen
precio y cantidad de equilibrio por eso
es posible producir todo este beneficio
bueno ahora regresemos a la situación
cuando hay control de alquiler ahora
estamos suponiendo que hay un precio
máximo de 2 dólares por pie cuadrado así
que por mandato del gobierno el precio
está fijado en dos dólares por pie
cuadrado dos dólares por pie cuadrado
si el precio se fija en dos dólares por
pie cuadrado qué cantidad de piso va a
ser ofertada si sólo se pueden cobrar
dos dólares quizás algunos arrendatarios
digan no yo sólo voy a derribar este
muro y emplear mi departamento o tal vez
si alquilan cuartos extras piensen no
voy a alquilar las habitaciones libres
mejor las tengo por invitados así que la
cantidad de espacio total en renta se
reduce a dos millones de pies cuadrados
al mes esto es una situación interesante
pues aquí en 2 millones de pies
cuadrados al mes tenemos que el
beneficio marginal es mucho mayor que el
costo marginal el beneficio marginal de
una unidad o un pie cuadrado adicional
es de más de 3 dólares mientras que el
costo marginal es justamente de 2
dólares así que no mercado abierto
eficiente y sin restricciones dirían voy
a construir más unidades porque la gente
va a obtener un beneficio de ellas y
podremos tener un precio justo y los dos
recibiremos algún excedente pero ahora
no incluso si hay este beneficio de más
de tres dólares como el precio no puede
ser más de dos dólares
y ningún incentivo para que los
productores construyan más
o quizás renten o vendan las unidades
que tienen de por sí ahora como
productor digo no quiero rentar mi
habitación extra debido a que no voy a
recibir ni siquiera mi costo marginal mi
costo marginal que anda por acá es de
más de 2 dólares pero solo puedo cobrar
2 dólares así que no quiero para ofertar
es unidad extra lo que sucede en esta
situación cuando el precio se fija por
aquí es que los consumidores que
alcanzaron a rentar estos primeros 2
millones de pies cuadrados reciben una
cantidad aún mayor de beneficio para
estos 2 millones de pies cuadrados los
consumidores afortunadas que alcanzaron
a rentar tienen un superávit de toda
esta área de aquí mientras tanto el
superávit de los productores
invariablemente se ve reducido su
superávit es ahora esta área de por aquí
muy bien lo interesante es que el
superávit total se ve muy reducido en
comparación de cuando teníamos un
mercado sin intervenciones ahora ya no
podemos acceder a este beneficio de por
aquí esto se puede pensar como una
pérdida para la sociedad
este beneficio o superávit ya no lo
recibe nadie ni consumidores ni
productores nadie en términos económicos
a esta región blanca le llamamos una
pérdida irrecuperable de eficiencia es
simplemente un peso muerto para nuestro
mercado ya nadie tiene acceso a esta
ganancia representada por el triángulo
bien lo que ha pasado es que ahora
estamos en una situación ineficiente por
culpa del tope máximo que le pusimos a
los precios es decir por culpa del
control de alquileres como era de
esperarse esta pérdida irrecuperable de
eficiencia se puede medir simplemente es
el área de este triángulo entonces para
calcularlo fijémonos primero en esta
altura horizontal del triángulo ésta
mide 1 mientras que este lado vertical
parece andar más o menos en 1.5 el área
el triángulo va a ser el producto de la
base por la altura entre 2 así que la
pérdida irrecuperable de eficiencia va a
ser igual al producto de 1 por 1.5 por
un medio déjenme escribirlo entonces la
pérdida irrecuperable de eficiencia es
igual al producto de 1 por 1.5 por un
medio nueva cuenta en 1 por 1.5 nos da
el rectángulo dividimos entre dos para
que nos dé el área del triángulo bueno
así que básicamente tenemos 1.5 por un
medio que nos da 0.75 millones así que
tenemos 750.000 dólares de pérdida
irrecuperable de eficiencia esto es una
pérdida para el mercado en conjunto así
que la ganancia total del mercado va a
ser 750 mil dólares menos que cuando no
teníamos esta situación de control de
alquileres o sea que la ganancia total
del mercado va a ser de 5.25 millones de
dólares que sencillamente son la
diferencia de los 6 millones menos los
750 mil dólares así que el control de
alquileres beneficia a los consumidores
que alcanzan a rentar pero
definitivamente no beneficia a los que
no pueden rentar no beneficia a los
productores y el mercado como conjunto
también pierde ganancias